hello there and good morning it is seven
a.m now Richard Suna knew the going was
going to be tough but even so he's
running to choppy water very quickly the
Home Secretary swella brabhaman is
accused of a serious security breach
she's also in charge of the immigration
and Asylum system which is under severe
strain we'll be reporting live from
Dover during the program and speak to
the conservative MP Roger gelt whose
constituency includes the manston
Immigration Center now packed to double
its capacity Plus we'll find out if Luna
da Silva's victory in the elections in
Brazil could help save the Amazon
rainforest it is Monday the 31st of
October
a stunning comeback Lula de Silva is
Brazil's president again beating Jaya
bolsonado in a knife edge vote and
saying he wants to preserve the Amazon
rainforest
criticism grows over conditions at a
center for migrants in Kent which is now
at Double its capacity as Charities call
for a kind and effective system for
those seeking asylum in the UK
question marks over safety checks as the
death toll from a bridge collapse in
India climbs to at least 132.
South Korea's prime minister promises a
thorough probe into the Halloween Crush
that killed more than 150 people in the
capital and left a nation in mourning
an exclusive Poll for Sky News shows
that public support for sanctions
against Russia could erode if the cost
of living crisis worsens
Ukraine seized the UK as its most
important friend its most important Ally
and there will be concerns that this
relationship could change
and also this morning
[Music]
we'll speak to a member of the Koji
indigenous people of Colombia we're
taking part in the world's first
environmental project to try and restore
their damaged land
and reaching New Heights will speak to
an army veteran Andy Reid who's become
the first triple amputee to climb Mount
Kilimanjaro
foreign
thanks for being with us Brazil has a
new president in a knife edge vote which
seals a remarkable comeback Lula de
Silva beat his right-wing rival the
incumbent Jaya bolsonado by the slimmest
of margins in his victory speech he said
Brazil and the planet need a living
Amazon rainforest he's promised to
protect it and the people who live there
from loggers Miners and the farmers who
are tearing it down nalula is the former
president who spent almost two years in
prison on corruption charges before his
conviction was annulled
foreign
so I can reach where I am above all at
this moment when we are not only facing
an adversary we didn't face a candidate
we faced the Machinery of the Brazilian
State put its service of a candidate to
avoid us winning the elections
thanks to the Brazilian people that I
should be grateful with my heart to the
people who voted for me and to the
people who voted for my adversary
foreign well look at the results shows
just how close it was Lula went 50.9 of
all valid votes cast while bolsonaro won
49.1 our chief correspondent shoot
Ramsey reports from Sao Paulo and a
warning his report includes some
flashing images
[Applause]
they all knew this election was tight
they all knew that a Lula win would
change the political direction of Brazil
a second round a second chance but the
tension was palpable
foreign
ERS gathered in Sao Paulo's police
Avenue
the results like a drip feed of Hope
behind at first Lula's vote started to
grow every game greeted with rapture
it was simple could he do it
but it was neck and neck to the end and
then it was done
Lula was President Kim Mayhem
[Applause]
if today I have this it's because of
Lola everything is because of him my
family was a very poor
oh yeah report and today I'm I'm living
in Sao Paulo and working with our the
Joby I love
I
within minutes people began flooding the
street heading for the celebration cars
hooting horns
a complete explosion of relief and
happiness the party was now fully
underway
[Music]
High School
back
oh Jeff bolzanaro is going to take it of
course we just don't know
new spread that Lula was going to appear
after meeting his campaign and legal
teams and taking calls from world
leaders
his supporters would have waited any
length of time this was The Impossible
Dream Come True
I think War the the world needs Lula
he's not the president of Brazil he's a
politician that the world needs so it's
beautiful
in those numbers they filled Paulista as
far as the eye could see it was
impossible to guess how many people were
here it was almost impossible to move
they sang the Lula campaign songs and
waited and then he was there
and they exploded once again
this has been a remarkable two-round
election which has revealed the Deep
divisions in Brazil
foreign
he's promised to reunite his country
it's going to be hard
still around to Sky News Sao Paulo
my reaction to Lula's win has come from
across South America the Mexican
president Andres Manos Lopez obrador
tweeted Lula one blessed people of
Brazil there will be equality and
humanism
Argentina's present Alberto Fernandez
said congratulations Lula your Victory
opens a new time for the history of
Latin America a time of Hope and future
that begins today
well on site here you have a partner to
work with and dream big about the good
life of our peoples
while the Colombian at president Gustavo
Petro simply tweeted Viva Lula
what's your Ramsay has the latest now
from Sao Paulo where Lula supporters
have been celebrating
for hours
and the votes were taking really quite a
long time to come in and it's an
electronic voting system so it is quick
but it was uh towards the end Agony for
the huge numbers of lular people that
have come out onto the streets
difficult to get an idea of how many
there are but it's it's huge number
every time we start to film this time
I think the thing to remember is hey it
is a remarkable comeback for Lula but it
was a really really close election and
that means the country remains
incredibly divided you know there's just
points in this I'm not sure the final
figure of number of votes that Lula won
by maybe over a million but the point of
the matter it's still incredibly close
in a country this side
and the two sides really are so far
apart and actually hate each other it's
difficult to see howler is going to be
able to get the country back together
soon I suppose
it's going to be some difficult days
ahead I think
all right I'm pleased to say we're
joined now by the minister for food Mark
Spencer Mark good morning to you thanks
very much for coming I should pick up on
what we've seen there in Brazil I mean
obviously you in the environment
department so you must be delighted that
a man who's come in in Brazil is going
to protect them yeah I think I think
that's huge progress isn't it and I
think uh it's great news to see
democracy happening all around the world
yeah and it's a huge comeback for a man
as well a leftist there I suppose well
but you know I think the environment is
a big issue and Brazil is going to be a
big player in that and I think this is
good news for Brazil it's good news for
the world okay let's move on to some
domestic issues and we've got to talk
about what's happening down in Kent at
the moment Mark I mean you've got an
Immigration Center there that's housing
4 000 people capacity for 1600. what's
going on down there I mean there are
huge challenges here you know I think uh
clearly we've got to break the model
that is bringing destitute people across
the channel there are some very bad
people who are putting innocent people's
lives at risk we have to break that
model uh of course when they get here
we've got to try and find a way of
dealing with them passionately and and
looking after them and processing them
as quickly as possible and there are
competing Ambitions to try and get
people processed but also to look after
them and and keep them safe but we're
not keeping them safe because they're
coming under attack here in this
um Center and not only that the center's
got diphtheria diphtheria and MRSA yeah
so we're working very hard to try and
resolve those challenges there is a
scheme that pushes people out into local
authorities to support them in in hotels
which were uh which we're we're working
towards with working with local
authorities but as you say there are
huge challenges but the answer to this
is to break the model that is delivering
these people to our to our doors to our
Shores and that's what we're working
very hard to to try and do we'll come
until you're breaking that model but you
say you're going to move them out into
hotels it's exact opposite of what the
current Home Secretary no so so we're
working with local authorities to house
them sorry we're we're so basically
we're working the local authorities to
house them locally there's a scheme I
think it's time 20 million pounds we've
invested in that scheme to support
people but the answer is of course to
process them quickly where they where
they are so why did the Home Secretary
then stop people moving out into hotels
during her her first tenure before she
she stepped away again
um she had put the block on hotel rooms
being used why was that because she
wants to process them quickly you know
we've got to try and make sure that
those who are genuine Asylum Seekers and
there are safe routes of course to to
get here via a a safe system she wants
to process them very quickly and work
out who we need to help protect and who
we need to return but you can't process
them if they're in these squalid
conditions can you because it's not
getting anywhere there's a huge log down
there isn't there so there are a lot of
people coming and we need to break that
model we need to make sure that we stop
these people coming across the channel
that's what we're working to do it's
been described as awful inhumane I mean
you can't be proud clearly we have an
obligation to look after these people
and to support them and to keep them
safe and there are huge challenges I I
acknowledge that
um we've got to try and deal with these
people compassionately and quickly I'm
glad you've acknowledged that because
looking at your record voting on
immigration it's it's quite a hard line
mark would you would you say that's a
fair way of describing it so I I think
we've got to make sure we control our
own borders that's what um people voted
for we want to make sure that the people
who are coming are are genuine uh
refugees and we've actually got a really
good track record you know looking at
all the people we've taken from
Afghanistan from Syria from Hong Kong
the UK has a very proud record of of
taking people from other countries who
are in Desperate situations I I you know
that will continue absolutely we need to
make sure that we're getting the right
people we should be pleased with that
but I'm saying specifically on on voting
to to stop people who've been here for
six months finding work if their
processes and haven't been put through
yet there's been some vote some
decisions made that have been made it
very difficult for people who come to
this country and I and I put it to you
now that that system is completely
failed that idea of that of lacking in
compassion for some of these people who
are coming here has broken down because
we have 38 000 come down I mean as I say
we've got a huge track record of taking
people from other parts of the world you
know I mean just look at the uh you're
creating the amount of people we've
taken from Ukraine that we should be
very proud of that record but those who
are coming we need to process as quickly
as possible to work out who is a genuine
Asylum seeker and and who could be
returned to a safe country that they
came from what about building uh new
areas to hold the new new centers well I
mean these things are all under uh
review constantly of course that that is
a huge Challenge and that's what we're
uh that's what we're seeking to do to
solve that challenge as quickly as
possible I mean you've caused it you've
challenged many many times the only
solution is what to tackle the business
model well that's part of the solution
of course that the other solution is to
uh is the Rwanda option to send people
to a safe country like Rwanda well we're
still working our way through that there
are a number of legal challenges to that
um but ultimately you've got to get to
these very bad people who are putting
lives in danger by putting them on a an
unseaworthy Craft on the other side of
the channel and sending them across
people you know putting their lives in
danger we have to break that model we
have an obligation to try and stop that
isn't the fact the case that after years
of of aggressive rhetorical towards
migration uh migrants we haven't got to
a system that's fit for purpose at this
stage and now we're seeing thousands of
people coming across we're seeing
tensions in in local times I mean
there's a fire bombing at one of the
centers yesterday Mark yeah and that's
that is currently under an investigation
so I don't want to say too much about
that but we've been able to move some
people away from that incident in in
Dover but that's an ongoing
investigation but do you accept that
some of the rhetoric around the way that
we treat migrants coming to this country
has has not been helpful and has led to
some of those increased tensions no no I
think I mean clearly as I keep saying
that it is a huge challenge that these
people are wanting to come across the
channel to the United Kingdom uh it is
the the bad people in this are the
people who are exploiting those
individuals they are taking their life
savings they are putting them on an
unseaw worthy vessel and putting their
lives in danger we have an obligation to
try and stop that from happening and
stop these people from drowning in the
channel is the right homosexual to deal
with this yeah in the prime minister's
uh reappointed her um you know she's put
out comes up and said that she made a
mistake I think we need to give her the
space to get on and do it I mean it was
a mistake it wasn't Anonymous honest
mistake there was some of the reporting
well you know I think you know often you
have politicians on here and you accuse
them of never apologizing and never
saying sorry she made a mistake she put
her hands up and said I'm so sorry I
made a mistake uh the Prime Minister has
reappointed her and I think she needs to
concentrate now on getting on with her
her job you know she's recruiting police
officers driving down crime
concentrating on burglaries and dealing
with this this challenge of of migrants
crossing the channel I mean can't you
concentrate with all of these noises
there are there is reporting there have
been many mistakes and there's also
reporting that those within her
Department are not happy with her having
come he's completely focused on the job
we need to get let her get on to it
you've got full she's got your full
fullback of course let's talk about um
what happened with the former prime
minister former secretary this trust his
phone was hacked it's been reported in
the newspapers recently
um I mean you're in government do you
use your government phone for any
personal business I do not no but I mean
you say you do get quite a lot of
briefing
um from the security services on what to
do and what not to do
um so you know it's quite important to
get that right I don't want to comment
too much on it because of course what I
don't want to do is is tell the world
exactly what that briefing says but you
do get a lot of support when you become
a government Minister on what is
appropriate and inappropriate as a as a
government so perhaps she wasn't
listening to The Briefing then if she
was using it well you know I think you
know as she said she made a mistake but
uh well this trust made a mistake as
well no sorry I thought you're talking
about the Home Secretary
the former prime minister clearly was
hacked you know so that is the first
thing you do is say oh my goodness I've
been hacked help and the security
service will help you with that with
that challenge now of course you don't
always know which is why you've got to
be super careful I think the concern was
that she was perhaps talking on a
personal phone and there may be some
stuff in there that leaves are open to
be called well we all talk on personal
phones don't we you know I ring my wife
maybe there's some little man in China
listening to the conversations between
me and my wife but uh you know you've
just got to be careful about what
information you use on which on which
phone and you get a lot of help and
support from the security services on
that and do you think it's time for some
more help and support for some of these
ministers as well being as careful with
security it is it is ongoing I mean we
need to recognize you know there are
states out there that want to do us harm
and uh you know Russia's being very
aggressive in in Ukraine there are lots
of people that want to do this country
harm which is why we have to be careful
let us a little bit about uh cop 27 the
Prime Minister said that he wasn't going
to go out to focus on domestic
commitments it's now being reported he
may well go what's changed well I think
the Prime Minister has a huge inbox you
know he's come into office he's got an
inbox which is full to the brim clearly
he wants to concentrate on the financial
statement and uh that's what he's doing
but if he's able to get through all of
that you know cop is very important it's
very important to the to the government
it's important to our future uh you know
and so we'll send out senior ministers
but that's yet to be decided who's going
to go would you like to see him go well
if he's got time and only he will know
what he's got in his inbox and in his
diary If he if he has the time but he'll
make that call and I'm sure it'll be the
right one we best have the Prime
Minister there on the world stage he'd
be first chance he's not just copies it
as well Mark is it he's going to get to
meet other world leaders there it's his
first chance we've got a war in Europe
well as a former Chancellor he's met
lots of those uh world leaders in in the
past but it is an important topic to the
government and we will send a serious
team out there just lastly before you go
because last time I spoke to you I did
ask you about this and we didn't get uh
any conclusion on it no straight guy the
investigation into what happened with
her it was uh kicked off in his long
grass when the ethics commissioner
resigned where are we with that now so
the honest truth is I don't know I'm
waiting for that report to come out
obviously we've had quite a lot of
turmoil in the system my understanding
is that Lord guide was very close to
coming forward I'm absolutely desperate
you said the same thing I know I know it
is very very very frustrating for me to
be honest because obviously I know I'm
completely innocent I just want them to
come forward with that report and say
there we go so you are expecting it
still to come come forward well
let's take a look at the morning's
newspapers now we'll start with the
Daily Mail reports on a picture bomb
attack on a facility processing migrants
in Dover over questions about whether
some sites are safe and sanitary
that's also the lead in The Times which
has the headline fire bomb attack on
migrants
Dental Express calls it a horror petrol
bomb attack which ended with the
attacker killing himself
the telegraph reports that the
government is planning to house migrants
in hotels alongside the public to try
and regain control of Channel Crossings
the guardian carries a warning from the
former head of the British army of a
wild west type attitude to National
Security and government
the Metro also quotes Lord Dana who
accuses the Home Secretary of
ill-discipline and poor judgment
the eye reports that Richie sunak could
reverse his decision not to attend the
cop 27 climate Summit in Egypt after
some criticism
all right still to come on the show this
morning over a hundred Refugee Charities
have signed an open letter to the Home
Secretary calling on her for a kind and
effective system for those seeking
Asylum I'll be speaking to the chief
executive of the charity freedom from
torture Sonia skis
I will be joined shortly by the former
British Diplomat Andrew Levy as the
government faces calls to investigate as
reports that Liz truss's phone was
hacked by Russia
well at least 132 people are now known
to have died after a pedestrian bridge
collapsed in India the bridge reopened
just days ago after a lengthy repair
work and officials say there are
concerns over whether adequate safety
checks were carried out before people
were allowed to use it
now the bridge spans the Machu River in
Gujarat State many more people were
injured as they tried to cling on to the
bridge as it fell into the water
actually reports
remains of gudrat's Heritage Bridge the
railings that lined it now form a ladder
for those trying to get out
most of the 233 meter narrow Footbridge
is now submerged in the river below
after it collapsed taking dozens of
people with it including children
buoyancy aides are thrown to people in
the murky Machu River some use them to
paddle back into the center to search
for survivors
all as more ambulances arrive to line
the riverbank
[Music]
the bridge had only reopened a few days
ago after being shut for six months for
renovation work thank you
now bystanders look on in horror at The
Frayed remnants
hundreds used this route every day
India's prime minister Narendra Modi
said in a message on social media he is
deeply saddened by the tragedy in his
home state and his deployed emergency
services to the area
this is a major search rescue operation
for them that will continue in the
coming days
the injured continued to arrive at the
local hospital inside panicked families
fill waiting rooms searching for loved
ones
as this tragedy caused by the city's
major landmark unfolds Before Their Eyes
Ashley
investigations are continuing into the
cause of a fatal crowd surge which left
154 people dead in the South Korean
capital Seoul most were young people out
to enjoy Halloween celebrations they
became trapped in a narrow alley packed
with thousands
well let's go now to our Asia
correspondent Helen and Smith who's
joining us live hello good to have you
with us so uh what more do we know about
what happened during this incident and
how South Korea responded
thank you
well really as the hours go by just more
and more horrifying details come out
from eyewitnesses about just how
traumatic how utterly terrifying it must
have been for those young people caught
up in that awful awful Crush
um on on Saturday night details from one
eyewitness talk about how people were
just piling like Dominoes on top of each
other it was a very narrow almost
slightly sloped Alleyway that young
people found themselves in there were
details about people being pulled out
bleeding from their mouths and their
ears how there was rows of people trying
to administer CPR untrained members of
the public trying to administer CPR
because there just weren't enough
medical staff to deal with just how many
injured and dying people there were it
sounds truly truly horrific South Korea
really now waking up to a week of
mourning a real sense of shock and I
think a kind of creeping sense of
incredulity as well about how this could
have been allowed to happen president
Yoon of South Korea he made another
appearance in central Seoul today at a
memorial that has sprung up in the
center there a lot of the shops and bars
and nightclubs around that District
where this tragedy happened remain
closed today and there's been some
really awful Grim detail as well things
like the soul
um uh City authorities saying that
they've asked the crematoriums in the
city to step up the number of bodies
that they would typically burn on any
one day to try and help support the
families and the bereaved through the
funeral process so really really upgrim
details and certainly a sense that
people are asking how this could
possibly be have allowed to have
happened because there were a hundred
thousand or so people in that party
District on Saturday night but lots of
people are saying there's nothing
particularly unexpected about that this
was a district that is always busy
particularly when there are festivals or
particular events that people want to
celebrate and then on top of that this
is the first Halloween that young people
were able to celebrate uh since covert
and South Korea's had some of the
strictest and most long-lasting covert
restrictions that the last of which I
really only got lifted in May so a lot
of people saying that this should have
been predicted uh many eyewitnesses
saying there were signs from a number of
hours before the crash happened that
things were really very very busy and
beginning to feel quite unsafe and many
people saying they saw very few if no
police at the why were there not more
crowd control measures people are asking
so I think there's a sense that there's
a potential Reckoning still to be had in
South Korea this week very much for
mourning for grieving for families to
identify they're missing but a sense I
think that anger May well Mount over
this and that questions for the
authorities about why more was not done
earlier to prevent this may well mount
okay Helena for now thank you
now an exclusive poll by ipsos for Sky
News has found the public support for UK
sanctions on Russia remain strong but
could erode if the cost of living crisis
intensifies
the findings suggest that 70 percent of
people support sanctions on Russia for
its invasion of Ukraine similar to the
78 who supported them just after the
beginning of the war
but the proportions saying they would
support continuing economic sanctions
even if they led to increased energy
prices has fallen significantly over the
same period it's now just 41 compared
with 73 back in March and a third say
they would oppose sanctions if it meant
Energy prices increased further of
course since March energy costs have
doubled for the average household
now concern about the impact of War on
the UK economy is clipped 82 of people
say they are very concerned or fairly
concerned and more people say they are
worried about the impact on the
Ukrainian people than on themselves
well let's bring in our International
correspondent John Sparks who's in
zappadizia for us this morning John good
morning to you so I mean I'm not sure if
the people of Ukraine will pick up on
that survey but they'll be I guess
worried to hear that if the energy
crisis continues the public support in
the UK could decrease
yeah good morning I think first thing to
say is that the city where we are
zaparisia has been hit by a couple of
missile strikes this morning we heard
the the Crump Crump in another part of
the city other parts of Ukraine have
also been hit Odessa cave Park Eve as
well the Russians going after critical
infrastructure they've been doing this
for the last couple of weeks trying to
turn the electricity off basically and
and the heating as well before the cold
weather comes in and I think it is for
that reason that I think some people at
least will be concerned I think they
frustrated even when they see and read
about this this pulse guys poll I mean
we are we are told regularly in the
streets we are thanked because we are
from Britain people are incredibly
grateful incredibly appreciative of the
the billions of pounds of military aid
that Ukraine receives from the UK for
many people along with the United States
this is the essential relationship for
Ukraine and I and I I think people
probably are looking for more support
and more assistance not less
particularly at a time when there is a
feeling that the tide is turning
in this conflict The Tide is turning
against the Russians if you look at
artillery pieces for example a really
critical part of this war the ukrainians
didn't have as many as the Russians now
they do and they have better equipment
longer range it's more accurate and that
in large part is because of Western
support so again people are really
really grateful and their expectations
if anything have probably increased they
do hear this argument for people in
Britain and elsewhere people starting to
doubt their commitment to Ukraine and
it's and its role in fighting the
Russians and they've got a pretty simple
argument for that they say look Ukraine
is fighting for Britain we're fighting
for the West we're fighting for
democracy and if we're not doing it then
you may have to do it in the future that
is the argument that they use when when
they hear these arguments that have been
expressed in this poll and John just
tell us a little bit if you can about
what's happening with this grain deal no
Russia decides to pull out of it at the
end of last week reporting this morning
that turkey Ukraine and the rest are
going to try and push ahead with it
what's the latest on that situation
yeah it's interesting I think what's
going on here is that the United Nations
turkey the European Union they spoke up
this morning as well they're basically
putting pressure they're putting maximum
pressure on the Russians to get these
these green shipments uh rolling again I
mean it's been it's a rare example of a
wartime success about 10 million tons of
wheat have been shipped through the
Black Sea Under This initiative to
Turkey where it then gets expect
inspected and then goes on to other
parts of the world what we know that
obviously the Russians pulled out after
a series of drone attacks by the
ukrainians on Saturday the Russians
remain in dialogue with the UN over this
grain shipment initiative they're still
they're not physically there in Istanbul
where it's all organized but they're
still in dialogue the um says it's got a
plan for 16 ships to move from today
they're still going to need Russia's say
so to get these these ships moving
across the Black Sea but I think they're
bringing as much pressure as they can
possibly bring again it's the Russians
to try and get these shipments going
again okay Jonathan thank you
now tomorrow we'll have a special live
show from the Imperial War Museum in
London looking back at the war so far
that's uh Ukraine a modern war live on
Sky News from 7 30 P.M tomorrow it'll
also be available on the Sky News
YouTube channel
or some of your morning's other news now
when police are investigating a fatal
shooting in South London that left two
men dead officers were called to relton
Road in Lambeth just before 8 last night
at reports of gunfire despite the
efforts of the emergency crews both men
died at the scene the Metropolitan
Police say that no arrests have been
made
Elon Musk has deleted a tweet with an
unfounded theory about the attack on the
house Speaker Nancy Pelosi's husband the
new owner of Twitter removed the Tweet
after he was criticized by other users
for sharing a link to a rumor about the
attack it's added to concern that
following his takeover the platform
would no longer seek to limit
misinformation and hate speech
now players from Arsenal have shown
their support for their teammate Pablo
Maori as he recovers after being stabbed
in a supermarket in Italy last week
the 29 year olds Defender who's on a
loan to AC moons at the moment was
stabbed in the back during an attack
that left one person dead now paying
tribute players as the north London Club
held up a shirt with Mario's name before
they went on to beat Forest by five
goals to nil
now I'll be speaking in a moment to the
MP for North Valley that's Roger Gale
and the charity chief executive Sonia
Skeets about the migrant crisis stay
with us
hello and welcome back now the Home
Secretary sweller Braverman has been
told by more than a hundred Charities to
create safer routes for those seeking
asylum in the UK now earlier this
morning I asked the government Minister
Mark Spencer why the situation down in
Kent was so bad
there are huge challenges here you know
I think uh clearly we've got to break
the model that is bringing destitute
people across the channel there's some
very bad people who are putting innocent
people's lives at risk we have to break
that model of course when they get here
we've got to try and find a way of of
dealing with them compassionately and
and looking after them and processing
them as quickly as possible and there
are competing uh Ambitions to try and
get people processed but also to look
after them and and keep them safe
let's bring our political correspondent
tomorrow Co news with us now tomorrow
good morning to you so look he said that
there are competing ideas of how to do
this but basically admitting that
there's a big problem and they don't
know how to solve it yet and it's a
problem that's on the desk of the Home
Secretary who's already had a pretty
difficult time in manston in my group
processing center we now learn that
there are 4 000 people in a facility
that's supposed to house 1600 and as a
result of this fire bombing in Dover
last night even more people are going to
be sent there he pretty much admitted
that the Home Secretary had not chosen
to allow people who should not be there
ideally for more than 24 hours to go to
hotels he said that was because she
wanted them to be processed quickly
clearly that is not happening we've had
even the former head of the probation
service saying that they're being housed
in inhumane conditions so plenty of MPS
want to see the Home Secretary do more
of the compassion and less of the trying
to get them processed quickly which
isn't seemingly happening we learned
last week MPS were told that of those
Channel migrants you came over in the
whole year of 2021 only four percent
have had their claims processed clearly
there's a massive backlog in the Asylum
system and the suggestion is that this
Home Secretary and perhaps her
predecessors have not got a grip on it
we already know that she's under Fire
over the reasons that she resigned from
Liz truss's government namely a security
breach which has not been fully
explained yet and I expect labor will
seek answers on that today but she's in
the middle now of a crisis over migrant
processing on the south coast and as the
minister was saying there there are very
few easy answers but many MPS wonder if
Sue Ella bravaman the Home Secretary has
been returned to her position for
political reasons having supported
Richie sunac and want to see her now try
to get a grip of the situation yeah
tomorrow for now thank you for that all
right let's bring in the MP for North
Island that's Roger Gale who visited the
Immigration Center in manston yesterday
and joins us now live Roger good morning
to you thanks for being with us when you
went to Madison what's the situation
like
it's much worse than it was when I
visited earlier last Thursday when there
were two and a half thousand people
there tomorrow wasn't quite right in
what she said the increase is because of
the transverse from Dover partly as a
result of the fire bombing yesterday so
there are now 4 000 people in a facility
that was designed to hold
1500 and that is wholly unacceptable the
staff are doing a fantastic job the home
office staff the civilian staff the
catering staff the Medics are all
showing compassion and doing the best
they can under very difficult
circumstances but these circumstances I
believe now
were a problem made in the home office
right a problem in the home office we'll
come on to some of that in a moment Mr
Gale but just tell us um you've applied
for an urgent question why is that
well because I think this is something
that has to be aired on the floor that
has
um the home office Ministry of State
rather generic took the trouble to come
and spent three hours with me with home
office staff going around the facility
yesterday I'd been before of course
um I'm delighted that Robert did take
the trouble to come because I think he
understands now what really the problem
is and I got the impression that he has
determined to go away and deal at least
with the immediate problem because there
are two issues there is of course the
longer term problem of a very real issue
across Channel migrants which also has
to be addressed in a grown-up fashion
not by dog whistle politics
and take that message back to his boss
in the home office do you think
I'm absolutely certain but uh Robert
genre will have spoken with their own
secretary last night
and what do you think he would have said
to her how will you've advised her that
she should proceed here because you will
have seen all the reporting this weekend
that decisions have been taken
concerning manston that may well have
exacerbated the situation we find
ourselves in now
without breaking confidence is I think
that Robert will be probably going back
and saying
not to book hotel accommodation as a
matter of policy whether that policy was
instigated by the previous own exactly
of this one I'm not clear but it clearly
was a matter of home office policy I
think Robert will be saying that was a
mistake we've now got to get people out
of mansion so that the job that it was
doing very efficiently indeed of
processing and moving people on can be
done again up until three or four weeks
about five weeks ago actually probably
the system was working as it was
intended to very well indeed it's now
broken and it's got to be mended fast
and sweller Brotherman has been brought
back in uh sir Roger I mean is she the
right person to handle this now
I'm not seeking to point fingers at the
moment but I do believe that whoever is
responsible and that is either the
previous Home Secretary
or this one has to be held to account
because a bad decision was taken and
it's led to what I would regard as a
breach of Humane conditions
and it may end up actually in the courts
as well if that decision is is found to
have been taken that people have been
held at manston past the 30 days that
they're meant to be there
well that is a matter of the courts and
not for me I am concerned obviously with
the people that I represent locally or
in turn concerned about what's happening
at Manson but I'm also concerned for the
staff but trying to do a good job under
impossible circumstances
and for the human beings including women
and children I saw a kid there yesterday
who was
younger than my youngest granddaughter
who crossed the channel in a rubber
dinghy it is appalling what is happening
at that level the trafficking is
appalling and that has got to be dealt
with as well but that's got to be done
on a pan-european basis and in bilateral
cooperation with the French that's the
only way we're going to solve it not by
as I say dog whistle knee-jerk policies
that will not work
what's the immediate solution to this in
your opinion sir Roger then is it to
build more uh capacity to try and House
people who are here the immediate
solution is to either build capacity or
more probably to acquire capacity in the
form of former student accommodation
which is available former mod
accommodation which is available and to
use that having converted it properly
for the purpose manston has not been
converted for that purpose I was given a
clear undertaking
by the minister and by the previous Home
Secretary but this facility will be
turning people around 1500 people a day
in 24 to 48 hours that held until about
five weeks ago but as a result of home
office policy
that is now broken we've got to get back
to using manston as it was intended to
be using used for the job that it was
intended to do
I mean do you instantly run up against
the situation here sir Roger that if you
build more capacity you then have the
problem as to where that capacity
actually is in People many people don't
want there to be reception centers
detention centers whatever you want to
call them eventually in their in their
backyards yeah so there's a huge amount
of nimbyism about this but look I tried
to take a responsible attitude I knew
that my constituents would be resistant
to the idea of advanced and being
advancing Barracks being used for this
purpose but I recognize the necessity
because the doctor the dots at Dover
were being overwhelmed we needed to move
people on to somewhere where they could
be processed humanely and decently and
properly and under the circumstances
that seemed to me to be reasonable I
visited the facility when it was being
built but then Minister Tom first work
Tom and I visited the beginning July it
was running extremely well there were no
problems there weren't people wandering
around the streets as being suggested
but Medical Care was good
that is breaking down as a result of new
home office policy and that is not
acceptable
I mean you've blamed the home office
policy um quite a few times during our
discussion so Roger what gives you
confidence then that this Home Secretary
said it was a dream to send people to
Rwanda previously who uh it's reported
stopped some of these migrants who are
in this Detention Center being moved
into hotels what gives you any
confidence that she will be the right
person to solve it I'm confident but
having visited the facility himself and
seen by himself yesterday the minister
of State Robert genre will take the
right message back to the home office
and say this has got to be sorted and in
fact I know that Robert has already
sought commission
um some Hotel space and that people will
be some people not a lot but some people
will be moving out today we've got to
accelerate that process so the man's can
get back to doing the job that it was
doing very well
okay so where'd you go appreciate your
time this morning thank you
now freedom from torture is one of a
number of Charities that's written to
the Home Secretary over the refugee
backlog and a lack of safe routes for
people to come to this country the
organization's Chief Executives Sonia
Skeets joins us now uh good morning to
you thanks for being with us uh your
reaction first of all to what we're
seeing down in Kent right now
well first of all I would really want to
remind viewers that the people we are
talking about in that facility are for
the most part people who are fleeing
problems in the world like torture
people coming from countries like
Afghanistan and Iran standing up for
rights that we hold so dear here in
Britain these are people coming here for
our safety who need to be treated in a
humane way so I concur completely with
our previous guests sir Roger Gale
um that this is an entirely unacceptable
situation it's a problem of the
government's own making and it needs to
be sorted out immediately sorted out
immediately what does that look like
mosquitoes
our ministers need to get their
priorities straight we put ministers
into office to oversee the
administration of our systems including
the Asylum system and we have had two
consecutive home secretaries who have
been asleep at the wheel in relation to
the functioning of our Asylum system
pursuing instead cruel and unworkable
policies designed to secure headlines
like the immoral cash for human scheme
with Rwanda they need to abandon that
cruel plan immediately and get back to
work sorting out a backlog which now has
more than 100
000 people in it who are languishing at
incredible expense to taxpayers and
terrible consequences for their their
help their their mental health in hotels
that is what we're calling on ministers
to do
I mean we'll leave the Rwanda policy to
the side for one moment because
obviously that is going through the
courts now but this idea of making it a
difficult place to arrive into was much
of the reasons to why I think it was
later than 29 years part of the idea of
making a hostile environment for people
coming here so this is what's been voted
for by some
absolutely not the conservative party
did not go to the last
date Manifesto promise to start shipping
Asylum Seekers people fleeing torture
um off to far-flung corners of the world
in exchange for cash
um the conservative party promised to
ensure that this country would continue
offering Asylum to people who require it
including people like those who we help
at Freedom from torture people fleeing
torture and instead what's happened is a
creeping uh
gist towards extremism in our politics
designed to create headlines to distract
the country
um from the scandal of millions of
people who cannot afford to feed their
children and to keep their homes warm in
the winter this is a political strategy
and it is having terrible consequences
for some of the most vulnerable people
of the world some of whom are reaching
our Shores seeking safety in Britain and
we should be providing it
and and how do we provide some of that
safety is the answer to build some more
capacity
I mean for a start
point out that
saying that part of the solution is to
be creating safe pathways
what is it's an audacious thing for this
Home Secretary to be saying because this
government has effectively been
dismantling those Pathways over the last
few years including schemes like the dub
scheme which was a really effective way
of reuniting people who were in France
for example with family members here in
Britain so we need safe Pathways more of
them urgently we need our ministers to
be turning their attention to the actual
running of our Asylum system sorting out
the backlog moving people through the
system we know that 85 percent of those
who are crossing the channel roughly are
are securing Refugee status if their
claims get looked at these are people
with genuine protection
um claims and if we can process them
quickly they will then be moving into
mainstream accommodation and we will be
reducing bills for taxpayers
um being amassed because of this hotel
situation which is is just unsustainable
for everybody
and finally how much confidence do you
have in the Home Secretary being the
right person to follow that through
zero confidence I mean she is a Home
Secretary who is not even trusted by our
security services and she is cruel we
can't have a Home Secretary
um who is
um intent on dreaming of sending torture
survivors to Rwanda instead of keeping
our country safe and ensuring that we
are offering protection to the small
numbers of people who come here seeking
safety here in Britain low confidence
indeed and of course that's a not a
minority view the the confidence in her
is sapping from across the political
Spectrum at the moment and rightly so
okay it's on your skeet's chief
executive freedom from torture I
appreciate your time this morning thank
you for being with us
now it's been reported this weekend that
when she was a foreign secretary Liz
truss's phone was hacked the suspects a
Russian spies
well let's uh bring in Andrew Levy a
former British Diplomat for some more on
this uh Mr Levy good morning to you
thanks for being with us I mean what's
happened with the former foreign
Secretary of the former prime minister's
phone's been described as a ill
discipline by General Lord Richard do
you agree with that
well the story that the mail on Sunday
uh Prince had said that she had been
using her personal phone
and the top secret information had been
compromised
um top secret means information that
could cause uh widespread loss of life
or uh severe damage to the National
Security of the UK or friendly countries
so given that the government hasn't
denied the story and Liz trust hasn't
denied it either I think it is a very
very serious matter
and what needs to happen now then with
this there needs to be a full
investigation to exactly what took place
to me it feels like there needs to be uh
uh cross-party parliamentary
investigation uh which may need to be uh
partially held in secret due to the
material that's been compromised
um of course it's not for me to say but
um that would be my opinion yes
I mean I spoke to Mark Spencer the
government Minister earlier and he said
that there are protocols in place
they're sort of lessons that are given
to ministers about how to keep their
data safe do you think that those
lessons need to be renewed do you think
that ministers need to get
um told again how to not be compromised
by using their phones for anything that
could be hacked
I certainly and I'm I'm I believe that
the protocols are there my experience uh
always was that they were they were very
clear
um but we've had two cases come to light
uh one is this um in the case of Liz
truss the other is the Home Secretary
using her personal phone in a way that
was uh looks entirely inappropriate and
so it seems like the protocols aren't
working in practice and that's a very
serious matter for us all not least by
the way because the foreign secretary in
the Home Secretary Arise at the core of
UK's National Security they're in charge
of the intelligence agencies the Home
Secretary obviously MI5 the foreign
secretary MI6 and gchq
um this is couldn't really be more
serious so uh the reinforcement
certainly
um investigation I think as well the
government perhaps weren't like that but
uh in the public interest I would have
thought that that is going to have to
have at some point yeah and I guess that
once this happens it's very much the
case that the genie is out of the bottle
I mean how do you try kind of recover
from the situation like this when
sensitive material is being used so uh
loosely
at the moment because we're basing this
on a mail on Sunday story and
um the fact that the government hasn't
denied it uh and Mark Spencer evidently
didn't deny it this morning
um we uh have a presumption that it
happened but of course we don't know the
detail and the security agencies will be
going through
um will have been for months already uh
a very detailed uh threat assessment and
damage assessment and in the light of
that they will be making recommendations
about what to do and of course I don't
know the details of that none of us do
I mean do you expect that there will be
a statement at some point very soon from
the Home Secretary just laying out
exactly what is what has taken place
here and and trying to give some detail
as to well when what went on
you'd hope so wouldn't you
um and I I think Yvette Cooper
um asked for something like that
um this is in one way it shouldn't be
highly political should it it should be
a matter that concerns us all and and uh
it's all our national security in
another way it does seem to be highly uh
political
um there's also seems to be some
infighting going on between uh the
previous Prime Ministers
um Liz truss and Boris Johnson and the
current prime minister and by the way
um the Russians love to exploit this
kind of thing
um they like to uh weaken uh governments
that aren't friendly to them the UK
isn't friendly to Russia certainly
um in the current circumstances and uh
they may well be manipulating this
information as well so we have to be a
little bit cautious about what we think
is going on but it would be
extraordinary if uh the government at a
very senior level uh didn't uh present
information to Parliament and to maybe a
committee of privy councilors in private
as well
okay Angela we do appreciate your time
this morning thanks for being with us